la première circonscription de la nièvre
s'étend à la frontière avec la région
centre un pôle principal est de
l'agglomération de nevers près de la
moitié des 110 mille habitants mais un
territoire qui compte 67 communes mêlant
urbain et ruralité marqué à gauche le
siège de député laissé libre par martine
carrillon-couvreur après trois mandats
lui même ancien député sénateur depuis
gaëtan gorce aura la lourde tâche
d'assumer la succession ps face à une
gauche fracturée l'un des enjeux de
cette élection législative est peut-être
d'ailleurs le principal au delà des
aspects politiciens dans les majorités
c'est d'élire à et des députés dans
l'allier qui défendent ce département et
qui demande à l'état de revenir à une
vraie politique d'aménagement un
territoire ne pas laisser une partie de
la france les tâches et d'autres à la
connaissance des dossiers d'un élu
depuis 1997 en marche oppose le
renouvellement perring où les chefs de
projet à la centrale nucléaire de
belleville sans passé politique mais
impliqué dans le rugby à neuf et c'est
comme dans le monde de l'entreprise
tous les 4-5 ans noah edf on change de
poste c'est intéressant parce que au
bout de cinquante a fait le tour souvent
de ton sujet comme moi de mes projets et
c'est bien de mettre une nouvelle tête
parce qu'il va avoir de nouvelles idées
parce que vous au bout de 5 ans 6 en bas
on a plus d'idées on a fait ce qu'on
pouvait sur ce poste là donc amener de
nouvelles personnes ça emmène des
nouvelles et nessakh emmène de la
dynamique après la percée de marine le
pen dans le département pauline
vignerons espère confirmer la tendance
et implanter durablement le front
national dans une zone qui se sont
délaissés et promesses n'ont pas été
tenues parce que tout n'a pas été fait
correctement et que je pense que
une peine et front national et moi en
tant que candidate pour les législatives
de la première circonscription
nous portons un projet neuf et novateur
sur énormément de sujets et que voilà
mouvement aider la france sur un
territoire historiquement inhospitalier
pour la droite c'est les espoirs
d'alternance sont portés par guillaume
maillard udi investi grâce à un accord
national il veut capitaliser sur le
potentiel de la circonscription mieux
cerner la connaissais pas japon va
produire sur ce portefeuille
nous sommes à deux heures de paris nous
sommes dans une terre qui est
extrêmement riche
individuellement par contre nous avons
retravaillé les filières essayé autour
du bois autour du vignoble autour de
l'industrie automobile nous devons
redonner une dynamique à cet axe du val
de loire qui est individuellement très
riche mais collectivement je pense dans
un dans un manque de vision politique
pour la france est soumise marit l'auto
elle a été chargée de bousculer les
socialistes sur leur gauche le but
confirmé le score présidentielle de jean
luc mélenchon arrivé en deuxième
position à nevers et troisième dans le
département la campagne pour les
législatives ont la france a soumises
s'inscrit à dans un cadre national et à
la suite de la campagne présidentielle
l'intérêt c'est d'avoir une majorité
pour pouvoir avoir à un gouvernement de
cohabitation
rarement la circonscription n'aura donc
été aussi indécise après l'échec de la
présidentielle le ps espère que son
ancrage local suffira pour conserver son
siège
mais l'équilibré des forces pourrait
déboucher sur une surprise selon le
nombre de candidats présents au second
tour et je vous laisse découvrir les
noms et les étiquettes des dix autres
candidats
et oui car ils sont quinze au total dans
cette circonscription a brigué les
suffrages des électeurs